This is 99% Invisible. Hey, I can't find that in the radio. I'm Roman Mars. Uh-uh. You'll turn to that station. I went to graduate school in Athens, Georgia, which is a great place to be from the ages of about 18 to 25. If you like going out to bars and listening to live music.
这里是“99%无形”。嘿，我在收音机里找不到那个。我是罗曼·马斯。呃-呃。你会转到那个台的。我在佐治亚州雅典读过研究生，如果你喜欢出门去酒吧听现场音乐，那里大约18到25岁的人生活简直棒极了。
Even though Athens is a fairly small college town, it's had a huge and important music scene for decades and the most famous band to come out of the Athens scene. Undoubtedly, was R-E-M. To be provocative right from the start, I'm going to say that REM's out of time is the most politically important album in the history of the United States. And this provocateur is reporter Whitney Jones, though I have to say, I don't think out of time is even the most important album in the history of REM. Actually my argument here has nothing to do with the music.
尽管雅典是一个相当小的大学城，但几十年来它一直拥有庞大且重要的音乐圈，而从雅典走出来的最著名乐队，毫无疑问就是R-E-M。为了从一开始就语出惊人，我要说的是，REM的《Out of Time》是美国历史上政治上最重要的专辑。而这位语不惊人死不休的挑衅者就是记者惠特尼·琼斯，不过我必须得说，我不认为《Out of Time》甚至是REM历史上最重要的专辑。其实我这里的论点跟音乐毫无关系。
This isn't one of those, oh it's a soundtrack to a generation or anything like that. Out of time made such a huge impact because of its packaging. The box that out of time originally came in led to a bill being passed in Congress and an actual concrete law. Let's go back to 1985. The pop charts were full of prints and Shina Easton and the youth of America were being corrupted. Tipper Gore and a few other elite women of Washington formed the Parents Music Resource
这可不是那种什么“哦，这是一代人的原声带”之类的专辑。《Out of Time》之所以产生如此巨大的影响，是因为它的包装。《Out of Time》最初发售时装CD的那个纸盒，促使国会通过了一项法案并成为了一项切实的法律。让我们回到1985年。当时的流行音乐排行榜上到处都是普林斯和希娜·伊斯顿，美国年轻人的心智正在被腐蚀。蒂珀·戈尔和华盛顿的其他几位精英女性成立了家长音乐资源
Center, or the PMRC for short. They put pressure on the creators and distributors of quote unquote, objectionable music. Musicians and labels called this censorship. There were senate hearings about this, and eventually those little black and white parental advisory stickers started appearing on albums. This set off a wave of censorship across the country. In 1990, a federal district judge in South Florida ruled that the rap group Two Live Crews album, as nasty as they want to be, was so obscene that it couldn't be sold or performed within his jurisdiction. 3 days after the ruling, two live crew played a show in Broward County, Florida, and after the show, two members of the group got arrested.
中心，简称PMRC。他们对所谓“令人反感”的音乐的创作者和发行商施加压力。音乐人和唱片公司称这是审查制度。为此举行了参议院听证会，最终那些带有黑白字样的“家长指引”小贴纸开始出现在专辑上。这在全国掀起了一波审查浪潮。1990年，佛罗里达州南部的一名联邦地区法官裁定，说唱组合2 Live Crew的专辑《As Nasty As They Want To Be》极其淫秽，以至于在他的司法管辖范围内不得出售或演出。在该裁决三天后，2 Live Crew在佛罗里达州布劳沃德县进行了一场演出，演出结束后，该组合的两名成员被捕。
And it was a live performance, I believe, that they found obscene with, you know, girls doing what would be like what my twerking, I think it would be a very early version of the twerking. Jeff Aerov wasn't there, he saw it on TV. And I just, it was just so offensive to me. Jeff was an executive at Virgin Records, and to be clear, he wasn't offended by the Ranchie lyrics or the twerking. He was offended by the arrests and the blatant censorship of the artist's work.
而且我相信，他们发现淫秽的是现场表演，你知道，女孩们做着类似于我的扭臀舞，我认为这将是扭臀舞非常早期的版本。杰夫·埃罗夫当时不在现场，他在电视上看到了。我只是，这对我来说太冒犯了。杰夫是维京唱片的高管，需要说明的是，他并没有被那些下流的歌词或扭臀舞所冒犯。真正冒犯他的是逮捕行动以及对艺术家作品赤裸裸的审查。
Jeff spent the next couple of days mowing this over and then he had a revelation. One of the reasons why politicians get away with things because there isn't an anti-constituancy. There was never anything to lose by baiting rock and roll because there was this canard that young people didn't vote. And, you know, within the next two days, the idea came to me like fully formed in some way, and I came up with this name, Rock the Vote.
杰夫在接下来的几天里一直在反复琢磨这件事，然后他有了一个顿悟。政客们之所以能逃脱惩罚，原因之一是因为不存在反对选民。抨击摇滚乐从来没有什么好失去的，因为有一种谣言认为年轻人不投票。而且，你知道，在接下来的两天里，这个想法以某种成型的状态来到了我脑海中，我想出了这个名字——“摇滚选票”（Rock the Vote）。
For Jeff Aeroff, the idea behind Rock the Vote was simple. Get young people to vote for politicians who wouldn't censor music. Yeah, it was that simple. It was the idea if you put kids in the game. The game becomes different. Politicians can no longer scapegoat music. They can't keep using us as an excuse. So Jeff Aeroff got about 60 people together in a Los Angeles hotel to talk about launching Rock the Vote. For example, was there,
对杰夫·埃罗夫来说，“摇滚选票”背后的理念很简单：让年轻人投票给不会审查音乐的政客。是的，就是这么简单。这个想法是，如果你让孩子们参与这场游戏，游戏就会变得不同。政客们再也不能把音乐当成替罪羊了。他们不能再拿我们当借口了。于是，杰夫·埃罗夫召集了大约60人来到洛杉矶的一家酒店，讨论发起“摇滚选票”。例如，当时有，
past and present California governor, Jerry Brown was there, as were a bunch of other record executives. So there we are, part of this virtuous circle of record executives who have spent a lot of their career being criticized for destroying the youth of America, and it was sort of like in a very altruistic way, I think we can do something positive, we can get kids to vote, we can, you know, it's cool. Also in attendance was Jeff's friend. Also a record labeled executive. Also named Jeff.
前任和现任加州州长杰里·布朗也在场，还有一帮其他唱片公司高管。所以我们在那儿，是这群唱片公司高管构成的良性循环的一部分，他们职业生涯的大部分时间都在因毁掉美国年轻人而受到批评，这就有点像以一种非常 altruistic 的方式，我认为我们可以做一些积极的事情，我们可以让孩子们投票，我们可以，你知道，这很酷。出席活动的还有杰夫的朋友。他也是一位唱片公司高管。也叫杰夫。
Jeff Gold. He was working for Warner Brothers, and one of his major projects at the time was trying to figure out how to package CDs. Compact disc packaging was the hot topic in the record world in the late 80s and early 90s. CDs have been around for a few years at this point, but record stores still didn't have a good way to display them. Here's Jeff Gold. When CDs first came out on the market, record retailers were kind of angry about them because their stores were formatted to display 12 and a inch or 12.4 inch squares albums.
杰夫·戈尔。他当时在华纳兄弟工作，他当时的主要项目之一就是想方设法为CD制作包装。在80年代末和90年代初，光盘（CD）包装是唱片界的热门话题。此时CD已经问世几年了，但唱片店仍然没有好的方式来展示它们。以下是杰夫·戈尔的讲述。当CD刚进入市场时，唱片零售商对它们有点生气的，因为他们的店面版式是用来展示12英寸或12.4英寸的正方形黑胶专辑的。
In other words, they didn't have any stands or display cases for these new CDs. So somebody in the record industry said, look, if you put a CD jewel case inside of a cardboard box that's as long as a vinyl album, and only half is wide, you can fit two of these long box CDs side by side in an LP rack. Problem solved. And the Ricker retellers said fine, perfect. And so millions of these things out of nowhere started getting made. Record people loved the long box. They thought it was the future. A headhunt show at EMI wrote this opinion piece in Billboard magazine in 1989 entitled, Why We Should Keep The CD Long Box.
换句话说，他们没有任何适合这些新CD的展架或陈列柜。于是唱片行业里的某个人说，听着，如果你把一个CD塑料盒放进一个和黑胶专辑一样长、宽度只有一半的纸板盒里，你就可以把两个这种长盒CD并排放在黑胶唱片架上。问题解决。而唱片零售商说好，完美。于是，数以百万计的这种东西莫名其妙地开始被生产出来。唱片界的人非常喜欢长盒。他们认为这就是未来。EMI的一位高管在1989年的《公告牌》杂志上发表了一篇题为《为什么我们应该保留CD长盒》的评论文章。
He writes, quote, I want to see the music industry continue to thrive and prosper as one of the cornerstones of entertainment. And I think making full use of the 6x12 CD-Carton is one way to help us do just that. But not everyone loved the long box. Artists said, wait a minute, we don't want you cutting down millions of trees to put our CDs in and then having people throw these things away, it's an incredibly wasteful and bad thing to do for the environment. Because the thing about the long box is that it was never meant to be collected.
他写道：“引文：我希望看到音乐产业继续蓬勃发展，成为娱乐业的基石之一。我认为充分利用6x12的CD纸盒是帮助我们做到这一点的方法之一。”但并不是所有人都喜欢长盒。艺术家们说，等一下，我们不希望你们为了把我们的CD装进纸盒而砍伐数百万棵树，然后让人们把这些东西扔掉，这在环境上是一件极其浪费且糟糕的事情。因为关于长盒的事实是，它从来就不是用来收藏的。
It had the feel of a big mic and ike carton. When you bought a CD in a long box, you'd open it up, you'd take out the jewel case, which had the actual CD and the album art in it. And you tossed the long box. There was no reason to keep it around. So REM have a record coming out in 1991, and they're saying to me and to Warner Bros., there's no way our record is coming out in a long box. We're sensitive to the environment. This is a ridiculous thing. Forget it.
它有一种大号迈克和艾克糖果盒的感觉。当你买了一张长盒CD时，你会把它打开，拿出装有实际CD和专辑封面的塑料盒。然后你把长盒扔掉。没有理由把它留在身边。所以REM有一张唱片要在1991年发行，他们对我和华纳兄弟说，我们的唱片绝不可能用长盒发行。我们对环境很敏感。这是一件荒谬的事情。算了吧。
And the Warner Brothers sales department is saying it absolutely has to come out in a long box or record retailers are going to penalize you. And that's when Jeff Gold got this idea. He could merge the two projects he was working on. They could use the CD Longbox to advance the Rock the Vote campaign. But first, he needed a concrete political cause to connect it to. And Jeff Eroff had found just the thing. We were sitting there looking for a raison d'être to get us into a political situation. I'm
而华纳兄弟销售部门则表示，它绝对必须用长盒发行，否则唱片零售商会惩罚你们。就在那时，杰夫·戈尔想到了这个主意。他可以把他正在做的两个项目合并起来。他们可以利用CD长盒来推动“摇滚选票”运动。但首先，他需要一个具体的政治诉求来与之挂钩。而杰夫·埃罗夫刚好找到了这样的事情。我们当时坐在那里寻找一个能让我们进入政治局面的存在理由。我正在
reading Newsweek or Time and there's this column article about the motor voter bill. We just said, we're going to help these people from the motor voter bill. This was going to be our first thing we were going to do. So there's this motor voter bill that's been bouncing around Congress since the 1970s. If passed, motor voter would allow people to register to vote at the DMV when you got a driver's license. It also allowed you to register by mail or when you apply for social services like welfare or unemployment, basically making it easier for lots of people, including rock loving young people, to register to vote. By 91, a few states had already adopted it,
翻阅《新闻周刊》或《时代周刊》，上面有一篇关于“机动选民法案”的专栏文章。我们当时就说，我们要去帮助这些支持机动选民法案的人。这将是我们要做第一件事。所以自20世纪70年代以来，国会一直在讨论这个机动选民法案。如果通过，机动选民法案将允许人们在去车管所（DMV）办驾照时登记投票。它还允许你通过邮政登记，或者在申请社会福利（如救济金或失业救济）时进行登记，这基本上让许多人，包括热爱摇滚的年轻人，更容易登记投票。到91年，一些州已经通过了该法案，
but Congress had never been able to get it passed nationally. Jeff Gold went to a political event in Hollywood about the motor voter bill, and one of the speakers was Columbia sociologist and political activist Richard Cloud. He said that writing to elected officials could help sway them on the issue. After Cloud's talk, Jeff Gold went up and spoke with him. And when I started talking to him, I said, What amount of letters would a Senator or a congressman take note of on a particular issue when he said, Oh, 150, 150 200 that would really have an impact and I said really that few he said yeah that you know people don't write so getting 150 200 letters about an
但国会从未能在全国范围内通过它。杰夫·戈尔去好莱坞参加了一个关于机动选民法案的政治活动，其中一位演讲者是哥伦比亚大学社会学家和政治活动家理查德·克劳德。他说，给当选官员写信有助于在这一问题上左右他们的看法。在克劳德演讲之后，杰夫·戈尔走过去和他交谈。当我开始跟他谈话时，我说，对于某一个特定问题，参议员或国会议员会注意到多少数量的信件呢？他说，哦，150封，150到200封，那真的会产生影响。我说，真的吗？这么少？他说，对，你知道，人们不写信，所以收到150到200封关于某一个
issue would would definitely make them sit up and take notice that weekend Jeff Gold was writing his bike around Santa Monica and i had this moment where it rushed into my mind this fully formed idea that we could take care of our e-m by turning their long box into a positive if we put a petition on the back of the long box that would go to rock the votes and i support the motor voter bill and we could distribute it to their respective senators. And I knew we could generate an unbelievable amount of mail doing that. Jeff Gold got on the phone with Jeff Aeroff and they agreed that this would be the strategy.
问题的信件，绝对会让他们大吃一惊并注意到这一点。那个周末，杰夫·戈尔骑着自行车在圣莫尼卡闲逛，我脑海中突然涌现出一个完全成型的想法：我们可以通过把REM的长盒变成一件积极的事情来照顾他们，如果我们在长盒背面印上一份请愿书，内容是发给“摇滚选票”的，并且我支持机动选民法案，然后我们可以把它分发给他们各自的参议员。我知道这样做可以产生数量惊人的信件。杰夫·戈尔给杰夫·埃罗夫打了个电话，他们一致认为这将是最终的策略。
They would turn the album long box into a piece of political machinery and they would flood Congress with support for the motor voter bill. That Monday, Jeff called R REM's manager with the plan. And he said, all right, let me call the guys, and I'll call you back. I probably heard back from him within an hour, and he said, great idea, they're totally into it, let's do it. So out of time, hit the record stores on March 12, 1991. And then the petition started rolling in.
他们要把专辑长盒变成一台政治机器，他们要用对机动选民法案的支持淹没国会。那个星期一，杰夫带着这个计划给REM的经纪人打了电话。他说，好吧，让我跟小伙子们商量一下，然后再给你回电话。我大概在一个小时内就收到了他的回音，他说，好主意，他们完全赞成，咱们干吧。于是，《Out of Time》于1991年3月12日登陆唱片店。然后请愿书开始雪片般飞来。
And I remember vividly, maybe four or five days after the record had come out. I mean, a very short period of time. And they had bags full of these things. It was really incredible. Nobody could seem to put their hand on what the exact number of that we got of these were. But I remember thinking, wow, after three weeks we've got 10,000. I mean, that's, you know, 100% of of her that's already half of what Richard Clouds said would make an impact and these things just kept coming in and drove
我清晰地记得，大约在唱片发行四五天之后。我的意思是，在极短的时间内。他们就收到了装满这些东西的麻袋。真的太不可思议了。似乎没有人能确切说出我们收到这些东西的确切数字。但我记得当时我想，哇，三个星期后我们就收到了10,000封。我的意思是，这，你知道，100%的……这已经是理查德·克劳德所说会产生影响的人数的一半了，而且这些东西还在源源不断地涌进来。
their canvas bags full of them coming in. About a month after Ariam released the album rock the votes political director plus two members of the hip hop group KMD. Weeled a shopping cart full of these first ten thousand petitions into a Senate hearing and they just left them there for Senators Windall Ford and a very young Chopping cart full of these first 10,000 petitions into a Senate hearing. And they just left them there for Senators' windall Ford and a very young-looking Mitch McConnell. In May of 1992, after thousands of petitions and Senate testimony, the Motor Voter Bill passed Congress.
装满它们的帆布袋源源不断地送来。在雷姆发行这张专辑大约一个月后，“摇滚选票”的政治总监加上嘻哈组合KMD的两名成员。推着一整购物车的前一万份请愿书走进了参议院听证会，他们把这些东西直接留给了参议员温德尔·福特和一个看起来非常年轻的……一整购物车的前一万份请愿书走进了参议院听证会。他们把这些东西直接留给了参议员温德尔·福特和一个看起来非常年轻的米奇·麦康奈尔。1992年5月，经过数千份请愿书和参议院听证会，机动选民法案在国会获得通过。
But then President H.W. Bush vetoed it. This was in July right in the middle of Bush's re-election campaign. Bush's opponent Bill Clinton took up Motor Voter as a talking point, bashing Bush over his veto. And the rest is basically history. Clinton wins 92. The bill comes back before the House. It's actually the second bill that the House takes up in January of 93.
但随后总统老布什否决了它。这发生在7月份，正值布什竞选连任的白热化时期。布什的对手比尔·克林顿将机动选民法案作为谈资，就布什的否决对其进行了痛斥。接下来的事情基本上就是历史了。克林顿赢得了92年大选。该法案再次提交给众议院。这实际上是众议院在93年1月审议的第二项法案。
Motor Voter passes the House. It passes the Senate. And then Bill Clinton signs it into law as the National Voter Registration Act of 1993. At the White House earlier today, President Bill Clinton signed into law the Voter Registration Act, commonly referred to as the Motor Voter Bill. And we get invited to the White House for the signing ceremony. And it's this totally surreal scene, Jeff and his wife are there, and I there with my wife and all the people from Rock the Vote. And Clinton at the signing talks about how Rock the Vote really helped to make the difference to get this build passed.
机动选民法案在众议院获得通过。它在参议院获得通过。然后比尔·克林顿将其签署为法律，即1993年《国家选民登记法》。今天早些时候在白宫，比尔·克林顿总统签署了《选民登记法》，通常被称为机动选民法案。我们受邀前往白宫参加签字仪式。这是一个完全超现实的场景，杰夫和他的妻子在那里，我和妻子以及“摇滚选票”的所有人都在那里。克林顿在签字仪式上谈到了“摇滚选票”是如何真正起到作用以促使该法案获得通过的。
As I said, I have long supported the idea of motor voter. More than a year ago, I promised this president that I would sign HR2 and fight for its passage. I'm pleased to be able to keep the promise today that I made on this Rock the Vote card which still has my signature back in New Hampshire. Shaking his hands after the bill signing, we identified ourselves as Rock the Vote. You said you guys got this pass and it was really one of the most surreal moments of my life. I want to stop a minute and point out just how bizarre this scene is. Remember Rock the Vote had formed an open protest against a censorship group that was started by the new vice president's wife, Tipper Gore. You know those little black and white parental advisory stickers, those were nicknamed Tipper Gors' husband was now praising Rock the Vote.
正如我所说，我长期以来一直支持机动选民法案的想法。一年多前，我曾向这位总统承诺，我将签署HR2法案并为其实施而战。我很高兴今天能够兑现我在新罕布什尔州的那张“摇滚选票”卡上许下的承诺，上面至今仍有我的签名。在法案签署后同他握手时，我们表明了自己是“摇滚选票”的人。你说你们促成了这一法案的通过，这真是我一生中最超现实的时刻之一。我想停下一分钟，指出这个场景是多么诡异。记住，“摇滚选票”的成立是为了公开抗议一个审查组织，该组织是由新副总统的妻子蒂珀·戈尔发起的。你知道那些带有黑白字样的家长指引小贴纸吗，它们被昵称为……蒂珀·戈尔的丈夫现在却在赞扬“摇滚选票”。
And it's a tribute to one group whose voice and organization was absolutely unprecedented. America's young people, they rock the vote, they got this done. So in Jeff Gold says, It was really one of the most surreal moments of my life. Yeah, I think surreal is probably the right word here. What's interesting here is that this campaign really could have only happened during a very brief period of time. Because before Clinton had even signed the Motorboter Bill, Jeff Gold had actually found
这是一个属于一个声音和组织空前绝后的群体的荣誉。美国的年轻人，他们推动了摇滚选票，他们做成了这件事。所以正如杰夫·戈尔所说，“这真是我一生中最超现实的时刻之一。”是的，我想“超现实”可能就是这里最恰当的词。这里有趣的是，这场运动实际上只能在一个非常短暂的时期内发生。因为甚至在克林顿签署机动选民法案之前，杰夫·戈尔就已经找到了
a way to kill off the long box for good. He hatched a plan and he went to talk about it with the chief financial officer at Warner Brothers, Murray Getland. I said, Murray, how many of these things do we make a year? And he said, oh, I don't know, 90 million between the group, something like that. And I said, how much do they cost? He said, yeah, 25 cents a piece. I said, okay, so you're talking about 20 to 25 million dollars a year, one of these expense on long boxes. And he said, yeah, I said, okay, so you're talking about 20 to $25 million a year, one of these expense on long boxes.
一个彻底废除长盒的方法。他策划了一个计划，并去跟华纳兄弟的首席财务官默里·格特兰讨论此事。我说，默里，我们一年生产多少个这东西？他说，哦，我不知道，各个组合加起来9000万个左右，诸如此类的。我说，它们要多少钱？他说，对，每个25美分。我说，好的，也就是说你每年花在长盒上的费用大概是2000万到2500万美元，其中一项开支。他说，是的。我说，好的，也就是说你每年花在长盒上的费用大概是2000万到2500万美元，其中一项开支。
And he said, yeah. I said, so what if we stopped making long boxes and we took that $25 million and gave it in the form of rebates to record retailers just to pay for them to reconfigure their bins. And we did it as a one-time, you know, discount or payment. And they got all the money we saved for the first year. And then for the rest of time, we're saving $25 million a year. As Jeff Gold tells it, the other Warner Brothers executives liked his idea. They took it to the distributor, the distributor went for it, and that was the end of the long box. Some stores got new
他说，是的。我说，如果我们停止制作长盒，把那2500万美元以回扣的形式给到唱片零售商，只为了支付他们重新配置储物格的费用，会怎么样？我们把它当作一次性的，你知道的，折扣或付款。他们拿到了我们第一年节省下来的所有钱。然后从那以后，我们每年节省2500万美元。正如杰夫·戈尔所说，华纳兄弟的其他高管很喜欢他的主意。他们把它拿给分销商，分销商也接受了，长盒就这样走到了尽头。有些店买了新的
racks to accommodate the long box for each of the dual cases. Others held onto their 12-inch bins, but started putting CDs inside of these reusable plastic cartridges. And record companies have been profitable and solvent ever since. So long boxes are gone, but the motor voter bill, which after it passed, became the National Voter Registration Act of 1993. That's still very much a thing. Between 1995, when the law went into effect in 2012, the percentage of the voting age population that is registered to vote went up more than 10 points, from 69.5% to 79.9% and in that same time span, more than 150 million
货架来容纳每个塑料盒的长盒。另一些店则保留了他们的12英寸储物格，但开始把CD放进这些可重复使用的塑料盒里。从那以后，唱片公司一直盈利且资金充足。所以长盒消失了，但机动选民法案在通过后成为了1993年的《国家选民登记法》。这仍然非常重要。在1995年该法律生效到2012年期间，达到投票年龄的人口中登记投票的比例上升了10个百分点以上，从69.5%上升到79.9%，在同一时期内，超过1.5亿
voter registrations have been filled out at the DMV. That doesn't even include mail-in registrations or registrations through social services for which the law also provides. So I think that proves it. No album is as important to politics in the US as REM's out of time. But really, their most important album, important about the things that actually really matter is Murmer.
选民登记都是在车管所（DMV）完成的。这甚至还不包括邮寄登记或通过法律也涵盖的社会服务进行的登记。所以我认为这证明了这一点。在美国政治中，没有任何一张专辑能像REM的《Out of Time》那样重要。但实际上，他们最重要的专辑，关乎真正重要之事的专辑是《Murmer》。
Musically, of course, it's not their best album. Automatic for the people is their best musical album. What, how old are you? I'm 30. You're a child. You don't know anything. Murmer. This name I got we all agreed 99% Invisible Let's Produce This Week by Whitney Jones with Sam Greenspan, Katie Mangle, Avery Truffleman, and me Roman Mars.
从音乐上讲，当然，它不是他们最好的专辑。《Automatic for the People》才是他们音乐上最好的专辑。什么，你多大？我30岁。你还是个孩子。你什么都不懂。《Murmer》。这个名字我得到的……我们一致同意，“99%无形”。本周节目由惠特尼·琼斯与萨姆·格林斯潘、凯蒂·曼格尔、艾弗里·特拉夫曼以及我罗曼·马斯共同制作。
Whitney Jones and Alex Kaplanman are the creators of Pitch, a documentary radio show about music on which this story originally appeared. Their second season starts in August, so you might as well subscribe to their podcast now and be the first in line when the new episode starts flooding in. Find out more at herepitch.com. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced at the offices of ArcSign and architecture firm in near Wild Heaven, Oakland, California. The full 99% invisible experience isn't just the episodes that you hear. The 99Pi crew are great at Twitter. You can follow us at Roman Mara Samliss and Skatingmingle and Trouffleman.
惠特尼·琼斯和亚历克斯·卡普拉曼是《Pitch》的创作者，这是一档关于音乐的纪录片广播节目，本故事最初就发表在该节目上。他们的第二季将于8月开始，所以你大可现在就订阅他们的播客，当新一集节目喷涌而出时成为第一批收听的人。请在herepitch.com了解更多信息。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的一个项目，制作于加州奥克兰野外天堂附近ArcSign建筑事务所的办公室里。“99%无形”的完整体验不仅仅是你听到的那些单集。99Pi的幕后团队非常擅长玩推特。你可以在推特上关注我们：Roman Mars、Sam Lees、Katie Mangle和Truffleman。
We're on Facebook, Tumblr, Instagram, Flickr and Spotify too. But I invite you to tell us which Aurem album makes you the happiest. It's a Judgment-Free Zone at 99pi.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们也在脸书、汤博乐、照片墙、Flickr和声田上。但我邀请你告诉我们，哪张REM专辑能带给你最多的快乐。这是一个零判断区，网址是99pi.org。来自PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。